that relationship really led me to
getting Nightmare on Elm Street and um
you know several like movies of the week
and things like that TV shows and all
this stuff like it all started and it
really just it happened quickly it
happened really quickly I mean things
when you're young things just you know
if you're lucky I was never the kind of
person that was like leaving one job to
go fly to the next one it was always
like 6 months even a year between jobs
unfortunately I always felt like I was
like never getting on that you know the
train of like super success um and so
like once I had that TV series just the
10 of us you know you just think oh
something's going to happen but it I
always felt like H there's like a
roadblocker oh I something's in the way
like I'm not it's not flowing you know
and and I often would get very
demoralized and just think like okay if
things don't by my 25th birthday if I
don't have another part I'm just going
to you know do something else I'll go to
graduate school or something and then
I'd always like get something and and
but Wes Craven you know meeting
him literally like almost every time I
was about to throw in the towel and quit
I always got a call from Wes and it
would be like I'm thinking of doing
Nightmare on El Street part three and
they've asked me to write the script
would you be interested yeah Dream
Warriors I have an idea for you to be in
it and I was like thank you Wes thank
you so much and same thing happened with
Wes Craven's New Nightmare I was I just
had a baby and I couldn't get an
audition to save my life I remember
going out for it was like technician
number three
for you know a TV series about you know
things that didn't even have names like
I finally told my agent if the part
doesn't have a name I don't want to even
go